le débat de l'entre-deux tour entre
marine le pen et emmanuel macron a eu
lieu il y à quelques heures voulait
peut-être suivi d'ailleurs avec moi sur
twitter quoi qu'il en soit voici donc
les temps forts en vidéo du débat est ce
qu'il faut donc retenir sachant que là
on est au plein milieu de la nuit quand
je tourne cette vidéo mais on sort en
plus de ça vendredi un décryptage des
différences de vision et le programme de
marine le pen et d' emmanuel macron du
coup n'hésitez pas évidemment à vous
abonner pour ne pas louper les autres
vidéos qu'on va forcément sortir dans
les prochains jours sur la
présidentielle et au delà alors vous
allez le voir avec ce premier extrait
qui symbolise assez bien tout ça sur la
forme le ton était globalement assez
posé beaucoup moins agressif qu'en 2017
sous marine le pen avait été à l'époque
extrêmement offensive trop d'ailleurs
elle avait elle même admis d'ailleurs
eux-mêmes ont vu le changement dans la
tenue générale du discours et l'ont
eux-mêmes admis dans cette séquence à la
fin du débat autour de la sécurité on a
une question si vous voulez bien sur la
laïcité
puisque le temps qu'on tisse discipline
et qu'il ya cinq ans madame le pen oui
c'est vrai
qu'on vieillir
je crois que ces facteurs je serai très
respectueux à votre égard vous ça ne se
voit pas moi j'ai peur que ça se
trouvera beaucoup madoff marine le pen
est donc apparues globalement plus calme
du côté des menus macron il ya eu un ton
relativement professoral qui est
ressorti et si on devait citer
éventuellement en point faible du côté
des menus macron mon cas je le voyais
d'ailleurs de vos réactions en direct
quand je diffusais le débat sur twitch
tout à l'heure c'est le fait qu' il a
pas mal coupé la parole à marine le pen
et d'ailleurs même dans ce que l'on
appelle les plans de coupe donc les
plans à des revenus de macron pendant
les prises de parole de marine le pen
est bien souvent ils croisaient les bras
avaient le sourcil froncé ce qui pouvait
paraître second certains comme arrogant
ou alors condescendant quoi qu'il en
soit je les ai vus dans vos réactions
c'est quelque chose qu'ils aient à pas
mal réagir autrement rien de vraiment
majeur sur la forme en même temps c'est
pas le plus important passons donc sans
plus tarder directement sur les
séquences fortes en détail le premier
affrontement majeur en fait de la soirée
que je voulais vous montrer c'était sur
l'international les deux candidats
étaient interrogés sur l'ukraine
emmanuel macron a accusé marine le pen
de dépendre de la russie et de monsieur
poutine regardez vous ne parlez pas à
d'autres dirigeants vous parlez à votre
banquier quand vous parlez de la russie
c'est ça le problème madame le pen ce
qui fait que on le voit bien dès qu'il
ya des positions courageuses et
difficiles à prendre mais vous ni vos
représentants de son là alors je vous la
fait courte qu'en gros il reproche à
marine le pen d'avoir effectué
effectivement un prêt auprès d'une
banque russe en 2014 c'est un argument
comptant beaucoup en ce moment depuis le
début de la guerre en ukraine marine le
pen a effectivement contracté un prêt de
9 6 millions d'euros auprès d'une banque
bien proche du pouvoir russe et donc le
rassemblement national continue de le
rembourser encore aujourd'hui alors à
cela et bien marine le pen a répondu
qu'elle avait effectué un prêt à sept
banques russes car elle n'a jamais
réussi selon elle à obtenir un prêt ni
en france ni en europe récemment
accusons donc ces institutions d'une
certaine censure politique et d'ailleurs
elle a accusé directement et minier de
macron sur le sujet monsieur mâcon c'est
malhonnête de m'empêcher d'obtenir un
prêt dans une banque française et de me
reprocher après mais de partir à
l'étranger vous recherchez vous rigolez
ou quoi en 2015 je vous a empêché de
trouver un prêt dans une banque
française vous étiez bien ministre de
l'économie j'étais pas ministre des
finances l'économie n'y a pas les
banques sur la question de l'ukraine
enfin pour tenter de faire oublier ses
nombreuses positions pro russie ses
meilleures années et bien elle a
notamment ressorti un tweet ses tweets
en fait datant de 2014 qu'elle avait
imprimé par ailleurs sur une feuille
comme vous le voyez actuellement ce qui
avait forcé ment comme d'habitude pas
mal réagir sur les réseaux sociaux le
deuxième moment fort de ce débat d'entre
deux tours c'est lorsque marine le pen a
attaqué emmanuel macron sur son bilan
économique
mais c'est marrant mais je rappelle que
vous êtes le président qui a créé 600
milliards d'euros de dettes
supplémentaires en cinq ans dont deux
tiers qui n'ont rien à voir avec le co
vide c'est totalement faux la dame le
pari semblait d'ailleurs de dette
supplémentaire même les deux tiers n'ont
strictement rien à voir sans les
chiffres d'ailleurs de vos propres
ministres évoquent 145 milliard pour le
colis tout le reste se sait de
l'aggravation de l'année parce qu'on
s'est dit irrité sociale
non mais arrêtez de tout confondre c'est
pas possible alors sur ce chiffre en soi
et les réelles la dette publique a
augmenté de 560 milliards d'euros par
rapport à 2017 soit sans doute 600
milliards d'euros d'ici la fin du
quinquennat dans quelques semaines mais
ses dettes en l'occurrence elle est due
à plusieurs choses notamment le co vide
en effet avec le corps d'un virus
pendant un moment les gens n'ont pas
travaillé donc il ya eu une baisse des
cotisations sociales ce qui a forcément
agrandi la dette est d'ailleurs sur ce
sujet la plus largement ça a été un
élément majeur de confrontation entre
les deux candidats avec notamment
emmanuel macron qui a tenté de se
justifier sur l'augmentation importante
de cette dette c'est le gouvernement je
suis fier qu'on ait fait ça c'est
l'argent de la nation mais dont
qu'est-ce qu'on fait autrement madame le
pen mais vous devez vous expliquer ce
que vous auriez fait rarement croisé
moments forts de la soirée c'est sur
l'europe un sujet qui divise là aussi
énormément les deux candidats emmanuel
macron a reproché à marine le pen de
cacher son jeu à propos de l'union
européenne votre projet quand on remet
brique à brique les choses en place
c'est un projet qui ne dit pas son nom
mais qui consiste à faire sortir de la
nasse appellent l'europe des nations oui
enfin si c'est que l'union européenne
vous sortez l'union européenne mme le
pen non mais pardon de vous le dire on
peut on peut décider de ripoliner tout
seul la façade mais enfin c'est pas pour
nous c'est une copropriété donc à un
moment donné dans une copropriété vous
pouvez pas dire du jour au lendemain ça
s'appelle plus la copropriété ça
s'appelle comme j'ai décidé parce que je
m'appelle madame le pen augmenté sur la
marche non je ne ment pas sur la
marchandise tout le monde sait que je
défends l'europe des nations tout le
monde sait qu est ce que je ne veux pas
dans cette union européenne et qu'est ce
que je veux changer et je le ferai je le
ferai avec des alliés alors pour être
très précis marine le pen proposait
effectivement de sortir de l'union
européenne et de l'euro alors avec des
nuances mais en 2012 et en 2017 mais
elle affirme à cette fois ci la en 2022
qu'elle veut rester dans l'union
européenne
échanges et d'une certaine façon les
choses et les règles de l'intérieur ce
qu'elle disait d'ailleurs lorsque je
l'avais interviewé dans le cadre de mon
interview face cachée des différents
candidats à la présidentielle il ya
quelques semaines autre temps fort de la
soirée ça concerne le climat un sujet
qui était très hâte d'où d'ailleurs
c'est intéressant de voir que les
journalistes gilles bouleau et léa
salamé on présentait ça comme un sujet
majeur surtout pour les jeunes même si
évidemment c'est un sujet qui concerne
en réalité tout le monde avec d'abord ce
premier point a évoqué une macro a jugé
que le programme de marine le pen sur
les énergies n'avais je cite ni queue ni
tête là on a sonné sur une controverse
clair lui votre projet il est très
transparent vous êtes climato-sceptiques
donc ses dettes oui vous avez dit
d'ailleurs que avec vous la neutralité
carbone 2050 c'est-à-dire les jalons des
accords de paris ça ne marche pas moi
j'ai lu j'ai vu j'ai été frappé une fois
encore par le rapport du giec et j'ai à
la fois un bilan mais je vais aller
beaucoup plus vite je suis absolument
pas climato sceptiques en aucun cas mais
vous vous êtes un peu klimato hypocrite
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être pour ça que
les gens ne croient pas à votre volonté
de régler tous ces problèmes de ce côté
donc marine le pen reproche à emmanuel
macron d'appliquer une écologie punitive
donc illico logis avec des taxes qui
pénaliserait du coup les personnes les
plus pauvres et elle a réaffirmé que au
coeur de la lutte pour l'environnement
eh bien il faut avoir la lutte contre le
système de libre échange qui
entraîneront qui vient à l'importation
de marchandises venant du monde entier
autre moment marquant c'est sur la
question de la laïcité lorsque ça a été
abordée les deux candidats ont affirmé
avoir de fortes divergences sur un tel
sujet il ya eu notamment ce moment fort
je suis pour l'interdiction du voile
dans l'espace public je les dis lady de
la manière la plus claire je pense que
le voile est à mme un uniforme imposé
par les islamistes je pense que les
grande partie des jeunes femmes qui le
met ne peuvent pas faire autrement
réalité même si elle n'ose pas le dire
donc il faut
libérer l'ensemble de ces femmes il faut
faire reculer les islamistes et pour
cela je le crois il faut interdire le
voile dans l'espace public dans les
services publics à une neutralité des
services publics elle est absolue par
contre dans la cité
vous allez créer la guerre civile si
vous faites ça je vous le dis en toute
sincérité parce que ça veut dire que
vous êtes c'est très grave parce que ce
que vous proposez parce que ce que vous
dites c'est qu'en réalité je
n'accepterai pas d'âme de cette somme
est sous la loupe que vous dites est
très grave on voit à ce moment là il
était interrogé sur la laïcité et marine
le pen a décidé d'amener la question de
l'islamisme elle a en fait reprocher est
venu macron de ne pas avoir mené une
politique efficace pour lutter contre
l'islamisme ça passe selon elle par
l'interdiction des signes religieux a
par ailleurs réaffirmé être pour
l'interdiction du port du voile dans
l'espace public ce à quoi s'oppose le
mal et le maquereau et les divergences
de vision était donc bien visible voilà
donc pour les extraits majeur après
évidemment il y eut quelques séquences
qui ont forcément circuler sur les
réseaux sociaux on a eu droit par
exemple à ce petit finito le marché
européen devenu macron finito ou encore
à une allusion à la ferme à qinze est
dont on a déjà parlé plusieurs fois sur
la chaîne de la part de marine le pen la
réforme que vous proposez est une
réforme qui consiste à payer les
professeurs en fonction des résultats de
leurs élèves s'est passé mckinsey qui a
proposé ça et je l'attendais celle-là
mais on est là j'ai du temps madame le
laisse
je pense que ça peut être ça peut être
là franchement pour le coup ça peut être
bien fait vous l'aurez compris c'est
resté un débat assez calme posé le ton
est certes monté forcément de temps en
temps mais sans jamais dégénéré en
résumer on pourrait dire qu'on a eu un
affrontement beaucoup plus sur les
projets que sur les personnalités comme
ça avait été beaucoup le cas en 2017
selon les deux premiers sondages sortis
par les médias dans la foulée du débat
les téléspectateurs ont jugé emmanuel
macron globalement plus convaincant que
marine le pen maintenant évidemment
c'est que des réactions à chaud tout ça
pour a forcément évolué sur le regard ne
serait-ce que dès le lendemain et donc
faudra voir l'impact concret de ce débat
s'il en a un dans les prochains jours
jusqu'à l'heure du vote évidemment alors
ce petit débrief ne permet pas de voir
tous les points qui ont été abordés dans
ces presque trois heures de débat vous
commencez à le savoir de toute façon il
ya d'autres contenus compost chaque jour
au quotidien pour continuer à vous
informer sur tout ça des vidéos qui sont
disponibles sur cette même chaîne
youtube du coup je vous invite à vous
abonner jamais c'est pas encore le cas
il ya aussi la chaîne d actu du jour que
jouer en descriptions puis par ailleurs
les contenus qu'on fait a notamment sur
instagram n'hésitez pas à vous êtes de
plus en plus nombreux et enfin
évidemment sur twitter notamment pour le
second tour le la soirée électorale du
second tour à partir de 18 heures je
vais lancer un live à ça se passe sur ma
chaîne twitch le lien étant description
on était l'un des premiers stream au
monde ce soir lors à l'occasion de la
diffusion de ce débat donc perçu
vraiment pour votre confiance je crois
que tout dit merci d'avoir été aussi le
droit encore une fois à sur ça avec moi
présente vous présent nos proches et on
se dit à demain du coup pour les écus
jour directement sur youtube
pour
[Musique]